how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and last night during
the super bowl we got
a full trailer for the falcon and the
winter soldier
this is the second trailer that marvel
has given us for the falcon and the
winter soldier and it pretty much had
almost entirely new footage now a lot of
it is just action scenes which
are more than awesome but we also get a
lot of reveals and a lot of details as
far as what the plot is for this series
so in this video i'll talk about the
connection with one of vision talk about
what exactly is happening in the show
baron zemo is back and he wants to get
rid of superheroes yet he's working with
bucky and sam
in some scenes in the trailer so what
exactly does he mean when he says get
rid of superheroes if he's working with
some of the superheroes
most importantly there are major
connections to the x-men in this trailer
and
the thunderbolts team so let's break
down what exactly is happening
for those of you who are wondering the
falcon and the winter soldier is going
to air on disney plus
march 19th this is going to be either
one or two weeks after the finale of one
division depending on whether or not we
get 9 or 10 episodes
and this most likely takes place around
the same time that one division takes
place since it was supposed to be the
first
disney plush show released but due to
kovan 19 it was pushed back and one
division premiered first so it's
probably safe to assume that the falcon
in the winter soldier takes place around
the same time that one division does
which means that it actually takes place
before
spider-man far from home because we
learned that one a vision takes place
before spider-man far from home so the
trailer opens up
kind of exploring the tension between
sam and bucky's relationship
they're not exactly the biggest fans as
we've seen throughout the mcu
but they don't hate each other like some
people might say they just sort of get
on each other's nerves like the
therapist says in the opening scene
why does sam aggravate you when she's
talking to bucky but they were both best
friends of captain america and they're
both military men who have a lot of the
same views and standards
now we're reintroduced to zemo in this
trailer and the last time that we saw
him was in captain america civil war
when he was trying to break apart the
avengers
and he kind of really succeeded in that
they were dissembled in avengers
infinity war which is why they
originally lost to thanos
so in a way zemo is kind of responsible
for half of the universe getting wiped
away from existence
but we learned that zemo is not done
civil war was not the end for
zemo's plan we see the same scene that
we saw on the first trailer where zemo
is at some sort of a memorial for his
family but this time we have new
narration coming from him himself and he
says
superheroes cannot be allowed to exist
and what's kind of interesting about
this scene is that as he is saying this
they showed the city
madripore now matchapoor has a
connection to not just superheroes but
a heavy connection with the x-men
specifically
wolverine but more on that in just a bit
now zemo goes on and says i have no
intention on leaving my work unfinished
and we see
the classic comic book mask that he
wears now the work he is referring to is
of course the work that he was doing in
captain america civil war
but even though he says that superheroes
cannot exist and he doesn't have any
plans on leaving his work incomplete
we do see him walking in madge report
with sam
and bucky which is insanely odd if you
consider the fact that zemo wants to
destroy them
and tried to and practically did in
civil war
and he practically mind controlled bucky
in civil war as well
so why exactly are these three working
together why are sam and bucky working
with zemo and why is zemo working with
sam and bucky well this is where us
agent
john walker comes in now in this trailer
it looks like during the series sam and
bucky are kind of going to be trying to
figure out who exactly is the better
captain america who is better to take on
the mantle that steve left them
yes he left sam the shield but in this
trailer we actually see bucky wielding
the shield as well
now we know that neither of them are
actually going to be the new captain
america and it's going to be us
agent john walker and us agent john
walker is really just a puppet of
thunderbolt ross the show is really
going to pick up where civil war
left off where the sokovia accords made
the avengers pick sides and some went
against the accords and were then deemed
terrorists essentially but
ross's main thing from civil war is that
he wants to control
the avengers he wants a
government-controlled superhero team and
he's the one that's going to appoint
john walker as the new captain america
and being the new captain america he's
going to receive
a new super soldier serum but it's going
to secretly be a serum that lets
thunderbolt ross kind of brain control
u.s agent john walker and this is most
likely what's going to bring
zemo and sam and bucky together bucky
having been experimented on and
receiving a super soldier serum himself
knows all of the negatives that can come
with it and of course zemo wants to get
rid of superheroes so in turn he's going
to want to get rid of the super soldier
program
it's actually been said that a lot of
characters from phase 1
are going to be returning and this is
mainly believed to be because of the
super soldier program
and anthony mackie actually said that
they're going to explore more super
soldiers in this series as well so it's
likely that the super soldier program is
why zemo and sam and bucky are going to
work together so they can take that
down because again it's really about
thunderbolt ross having his own
super soldier army that he can control
now the super soldier program is really
the weapon x program that thunderbolt
ross was working on in the incredible
hulk it's just a different name and it's
believed
that ross is going to try and start this
program again
and the new super soldier serum is going
to be used on john walker and that's how
he controls him
this is also linked to wolverine because
wolverine is
weapon x yes there is the program weapon
x but he was literally the 10th weapon
in the weapon x program
and quick spoiler alert i'm about to
dive into some one division episode 5
spoilers so if you haven't seen it or
heard yet about its big ending you
should click away now
so after watching one division episode 5
the x-men are now
technically in the marvel cinematic
universe marvel brought in quicksilver
from the fox universe who
is an x-men in that universe so now an
x-men character technically does exist
in the mcu so marvel has begun to
incorporate mutants and now in the
falcon and the winter soldier they're
going to
match report as we see in the trailer
here as i mentioned before this is
heavily associated with mutants in fact
it's used as a hideout for many and
actually wolverine specifically has
spent a lot of time in magipore
in fact at one point in time his wife at
the time was in charge of the city and
then at another point in time
wolverine's son
dakin was in charge as well so lots of
wolverine connections here with the
weapon x program and the city of
madrapore
match report at one point was also taken
over by hydra and we know that hydra
plays a huge part in captain america
storyline and
buckies so i wouldn't be surprised if
hydra is involved in this somehow plus
we've had the hydro commercials in one
division
now in this we get another look at some
of the other villains in the show erin
kelly men's character which her identity
is still
unknown and nothing yet is listed for
her anywhere so right now all that we
really know is that she is a part of the
flag smashers
this is the group that she's with that
has the hands painted over their mask
now in the comics there is a character
called flagsmaster but he's just a
single character it's not a group but he
himself
does lead a group that tries to unite
the world by getting rid of their
identities so there could be a
connection here with the flax masters
trying to get rid of the avengers and
other superheroes as well which means
they could end up teaming with baron
zemo
or at the same time they could simply be
working for thunderbolt ross who may
know that sam bucky
and zemo are trying to stop his weapon x
program so he sends them to try and stop
sam bucky and zemo we then see sharon
carter come out of nowhere and she comes
out of nowhere because she has been on
the run for breaking the sokovia accords
now the sokovia chords are actually
mentioned again in one division episode
5.
they talk about wanda breaking the
sokovia accords so it's clear that
despite whatever happened in avengers
infinity war and avengers in game
despite these heroes helping save the
world
they still care about the sokovia
accords and they're still trying to
track down people who win against the
sokovia accords so
sharon carter so sharon carter right now
is on the run because in captain america
civil war she helped captain america sam
and bucky so once again this show is
really going to pick off
kind of where civil war left off now
obviously she was helping sam and bucky
before and it looks like she's going to
be joining them and helping them again
and judging by this fight scene that we
see she's probably going to have a lot
more screen time
now zemo is returning agent walker is
going to be under the control of
thunderbolt ross so this could be the
start of the thunderbolts and keep in
mind that ross
is red hulk in the comics and he's been
rumored to be making an appearance in
the marvel cinematic universe
more evidence of this is that kevin
feige stated in disney's investors day
that abomination is going to be coming
back in she-hulk and he's going to be
played by tim roth the same one that
played abomination in the incredible
hulk so look out for the thunderbolts
making their way to the mcu because it
does look like they could be getting set
up in the falcon and the winter soldier
series
now the trailer ends on sort of an
inside joke sam and bucky are messing
around and they're having a staring
contest with each other
then the therapist intervenes and says
just blink i mean
how old are you and it's kind of an
inside joke and wink at us fans because
we know that bucky is actually over a
hundred years old
so that is my breakdown of the falcon
and the winter soldier trailer i'll be
doing watch parties for this like i've
been doing for one division
and of course i'll be doing more
theories and breakdowns coming up soon
so be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest
videos on the falcon and the winter
soldier one division and of course
more mcu content don't forget to like
the video and for live updates you can
always follow me on twitter and
instagram as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
me
you